so
dad guess what tomorrow is the day you
return this horrific tablecloth to the
store
or stab it because it's an alien see it
changes patterns it's absolutely an
alien having trouble holding a
consistent geometric pattern
honestly this level of paranoia is a
direct result of watching too much rick
and morty trust nothing
everything is nothing or something
umbrella paintings
but also tomorrow is your one year
anniversary back in our lives
celebrating arbitrary anniversaries
because you can i'm gonna make you
flying saucer-shaped pancakes and yes as
another rick points out shortly regular
shaped pancakes are also flying saucer
shapes so
this sin is for teasing that you're
making fun shaped pancakes when in fact
you are not
beth is a monster considering breakfast
is on the table i think we're meant to
believe it's 6 a.m and there's no way
this family has gathered for a fully
prepared meal by
six [ __ ] a.m nope in this episode we
learned that rick's smarty brainwaves
need morty's dummy brainwaves to keep
rick untraceable or some such bullsh
get here in the opening credits he
straight up leaves morty to die so
what's that about
my son's been abducted you hate me for
buying those coins
to be fair jerry was frozen when morty
was abducted and therefore wouldn't
understand the full reason beth is upset
normally jerry deserves the yelling but
not this time beth also coin collections
jeez rick what is this place the citadel
of ricks
it's the secret headquarters for the
council of ricks and where's the
counseling center for jerry and beth's
considering all ricks have a morty and
all mortys have a jerry and beth who
would be distraught because their sons
are missing
turn your boring old morty into a hot
fashion statement
this is a ricktastic concept but he can
see that the ricky's trying to sell his
goods to has handcuffs on and is being
transported by some form of authority
right how does he expect to close a deal
here exactly
it's supposed to be funny because they
have different hair styles but it's not
cliche
if his body was stuffed into the wood
chipper starting with the head then how
is the arm still in one piece
yeah so does the scientist formerly
known as rick
why isn't he here in handcuffs because
he's dead too
it's half cap shaming so as they say in
canada p
suit making fun of canadians wait is
that a sin
i can't remember ron morty and then our
rick and morty run by many other rick
and mortys who would easily attempt to
stop them but don't even try
perplexing considering everyone thinks
our rick is a dangerous rick killer but
oh well
on to the portal pandemonium i feel like
this is a good time to revisit the how
the f
does the portal pewpew gun work portion
of the program does he just
think of a specific destination or are
the locations random and somehow managed
to spew fire insects and tentacles at
the perfect moment
the incredibly convenient timing is
simple either way based on the fact that
we only see asses and no hands what is
the purpose of the giant rolls of toilet
paper who would even use them
and how are the rear ends so clean if
the ground around them is covered in
feces
this is the least subtle symbolic anal
penetration since the ending of north by
northwest
yeah i'd like to order one large person
with extra people please
white people no no no black people and
hispanic on half
racist pizza yes i'd like to order one
large sofa chair this is a pretty
funny running gag but with all these
different worlds it makes me wonder why
the rix looked the same at the council
or was pizza rick or telephone ricker
greasy grandma rick
and we see a hammer morty later so
clearly these types exist
i continue to take issue with the use of
portals in this episode and here's why
rick splats out a whole bunch of options
the enemy appears and they say
they could have gone into any one of
these we lost them which means they
aren't tracking our rick and morty
so how would they have known to follow
them into the farty mcpoop smith world
in the first place
i just want to point out that there
appears to be a fruit bowl on the bottom
shelf which is a really dumb place for
fruit and bowls in the combination
thereof
anything else yeah more phone sticks
please so they're eating
phones just because they went into a
different dimension does not mean they
have a different digestive system bad
guys avoid looking around the room
thereby allowing the good guys to slip
away cliche
they look exactly like us so in order to
avoid confusion i'm gonna mark us each
with a red x right now
but they're also wearing different
clothing so you could just go with that
as the identifier
also there must be additional exits to
this restaurant because i'll rick and
morty straight up escape
so rather than marking x's on foreheads
perhaps watch those doors
hey you didn't pay your bill you said
holy chairs are sentient
wrong advertising wow so people need
help figuring out what to buy and then
you help them it's a little more
complicated than that
it is not also if the other jerry's
think bulk jerry is useless why would he
be brought along for missions in the
first place
appears there are more than enough ricks
for the job you're missing my symphony
hey i'll take it over mumford and sons
i'm pretty sure the rolling stones
review for that mumford and sons album
was it's the equivalent of listening to
a thousand naked children being tortured
so this race might still be too close to
call we will find our peace in the next
world
show now asks us to believe that the
captive mortys have had enough time to
form a cult and mine this cave prison
for the resources to create cloaks
printed propaganda and a precise razor
to shave their heads
the pointy thing isn't piercing morty
any longer and so all the tortured
mortys spend one beautiful second
believing they are freed before
realizing they are likely falling to
their death
how special owning a life is rough
poster that shows the golf ball on the
green
and barely any rough saved your ass all
right morty don't break an arm jerking
yourself off
i mean you can't really do that right
right
this is the receiver yeah but where's
the transmitter
cliffhangers no eye boogers lifters
hookers
stalkers
[Music]
homer i told you this morning no guns at
the dinner table
you no no no me
you bring up the holograms
[Music]
and i hate to get all andy rooney about
it but when did bright colored plastic
cows pigs and rabbits get to be art
coffee time
you wake up it's time for coffee
advertising
wow so people need help figuring out
what to buy and then
you help them cheese it's milk
that you chew you know jerry i'm not
going to tell you that these will
increase in value or
even hold their current value the truth
is you bought them because you like them
they have value to you
that's what matters
i don't want them to gain another yard
you blitz all night